hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to with the addition of
more girl our dance with caution now I
know I said I was gonna get back to this
game way earlier than I did and I didn't
but we're here now and we're having fun
but before I go on to the left ending or
the left entire game that's ready there
I found this which the lucky cat start
scratching his wall and then I went in
this room and I saw the most amazing
sight Sonic
for some reason Sonic is in my cabin in
the woods and I don't know why he's in
my cabin in the woods
and I actually don't know what file I
can say here crap no essence okay I
think this is right after I go to the
right path so here we go hello hi how's
it going uh Sonic I really liked you in
sonic boom I would rather have you
forget that I'm Sonic apparently Oh what
exactly are you doing to my cabin Sonic
well I came to see if you had any games
of mine but uh you don't owe mark why do
you have to be like that hey it's not my
fault nobody really asks for Sonic games
anyway I found this secret door and
decided this pretty cool hideout okay
but don't go stealing my stuff mark
what's he gonna steal some dirty chairs
how dare you Danny sick Bing hey it took
me ages to get those chairs out here I
thought the only thing you brought here
was a computer hey cut it out
stop being smarter than me and sexier by
the way how about you play a Sonic game
on your channel mark no why don't why
would I do that ever I would recommend
Sonic Heroes
Oh totally play a Sonic game for your
channel in real life yes great it'll be
grand old times I'm sure it will okay
then I'll get out of your hair uh quills
okay nobody tell him I'm actually not
gonna play that at all ever forever no
way now it would be quite rude to open
this why it's my cabin
why couldn't I open my own thing in my
own cabin okay wow this was a good
adventure by Sonic I have no idea what
you were there mark you really gonna
splay Sonic game I'll think about it
and I've thought about it and the answer
is no all righty then to the left
hey Danny maybe this is a generator it
doesn't look like a generator well it
doesn't hurt to try it it might hurt if
I fall down 20 storeys and die hey hey
there's marks on the walls let's see no
I've already read this come on this
decision will dry so I know this is why
I'm back here to the left to the left
put everything in the box in left maybe
what's gonna happen why say I know
exactly what's gonna happen oh no not
that way
whoa
everything got awesome hell yeah
Oh okay seizure warning everybody whoa
ha that's a good mom I love their face
oh man it's so cool it's so cool Donny
bashed him I forgot that he was dead in
the story line uh whoa Danny what the
hell oh this is gonna be much cooler
than the other way hello baby
ah no this was not here before none of
this was here before what in the world
happened to this place what happened to
my cabin word shot it go I can't see
Sonic okay all right thanks me
I forgot hmm damn it Danny come back and
be a man if you can possibly be any
manlier than you already are because
he's so manly okay so no I forgot about
that
okay hello oh no where is everybody
wait where did everybody go maybe they
went back to my house yeah it's probably
good okay I'll just wander through the
dangerous forest alone that killed Bob
and Wade in one hit last time oh okay
what the hell
okay ml was I that I okay I'm done
Oh get started ready that's your main
concern you just table dance your way
through the woods and up a tree okay
whatever I gotta get inside wait a
minute no no stop the earth is disturbed
the earth is disturbed thirst was
disturbed by tiny box Tim's grave I
wonder where everybody is oh well time
to ignore that and then go to bed
I checked the whole house Elway probably
convinced everybody to get out of there
like little babies okay
yeesh I'm soaked I should probably get
out of these wet clothes oh oh I was
gonna have more pomp and circumstance to
that
well I'm pooped I'm going to bed who
cares where my friends are let's just
consider them lost forever all right
no Tony mix Tim whose only disc wait why
was he American fusion tiny box Tim left
for the box I love it I had no idea the
tiny box in was gonna be in the luvs am
i oh man I can't wait I'm so excited
sorry I'm so excited I just love the big
look I didn't sleep well
I never sleep well these days anymore
hello buxom morning Tim good morning to
you mark
oh it's evil Tim that's dead hey Tim did
you hear anyone come in last night
uh no why darn it I don't know where all
the guys went what I went to sleep and
obviously I didn't care about them so
why am i concerned now hey should I play
asses and angels hell yeah I show Oh big
bear Barney isn't he adorable he looks a
little mean
dear market bar today I whacked my son
onto his butt with a bottle of chocolate
milk good times is that a game that I
played because I'm not getting that
reference okay moving on
kids if you don't even true you'll never
grow up to be as big and strong as me
with
i thrown what's in my box keep most of
my clothes
bla bla bla have you bought a shirt yet
the charity shirts are already being
sent out as we speak player what do you
say me what do you say to me can't play
the piano but it sure does bring in the
ladies of course that's assuming they
sell out get into my attic in the first
place well considering my creepy cabin
in the woods I don't think anybody is
gonna be visiting me any time in the
future
great ok cool I really do wish I had a
attic full of weapons it's a blue ball
everybody make blue ball jokes ray ok so
what the hell is going on with everybody
else oh yeah yeah ok yeah all right
what's happened to my pillars and when
did I get pillars what happened to my
rock wait what happened to my plants I
don't know everything's gonna hello mark
having fun hi Tim tiny bucks Tim what
did you do to my house I thought it
needed some renovations no tiny box Tim
how did you do this the name tiny box
stepdad a log with my old South besides
the one that's our the other Robin uh
what you can call me the hardwood I'd
rather not you know that sounds awfully
raunchy I hardwood I'm going to kill you
where you stand markiplier oh yeah how
exactly you're gonna do that ah yeah I
thought so why don't you come up with an
elaborate scheme to kill me Wow
you'll never get out of here alive ok
bye
oh wait where are you doing I'm walking
out the door oh yeah you can't do that
and why not ah because you won't get out
alive I'm leaving Mike hold on oh did
I've won did I've won the game hello
baby hello baby sugar skin yeah I've
never called anyone that ever okay bye
okay everything's fine I'll just go to
the police they'll know what to do
and Bob still has the wharfs ash yeah
everything should be fine why am I
worried about all this who know I left
Tim behind I left the real Jim behind
and I'll never get out of your life
oh no they'll know what to do where did
all my asses and Angels go oh well seems
rather dead here
did I wander into hello hi weird welcome
in order to pass the sacred 7 floors you
must answer all 6 of my questions wait
if there are 7 floors Jim there be seven
questions ah
no is this Wade's thing with a 777 there
are only only six questions the topic of
the questions shall be decided by the
wheel yeah we love we love things which
questions are base up are you talking
about the wheel of mythicality
catchy let us spin the view
please be poop please poop wait that
changed weird all the poop doh oh my god
inside the poop the whole time all right
looks like the topic is markiplier okay
cool wow I totally didn't see that
coming I really didn't I saw poop coming
how many people does it take to beat a
monkey at chess wait dude there were
four of us right that's in relation to a
music video that we did for I remember
this it was four well done please
continue to the next floor thank you but
what why is this city like this is this
what everybody does who was the leader
of the Illuminati oh my god this is a
trick question because in the game
it was spoderman I remember Shrek
turning the spider spawner man no he did
what no that's what happened nuts really
what happened no he turned in this
folder man it was Spota man the whole
time I don't know who the hell swagman
Knight
oh no that was of course he turned into
swag tonight Oh
after spoderman he was swag tonight okay
I'm wrong the twist ending okay I got it
I don't even know myself
apparently the berries are white there
but a full of scheisse that's exactly my
belly was hurting after eating some of
them well done mark a blur you know to
eat the bad berries thanks what about
all this gold can I have okay bye hello
what did Mark say to ease the pain in
the hots often yeah blah blah blah blah
well done continued doses if I know what
I'm doing except for that time that I
didn't know what I doing everybody shop
you didn't see that in which episode of
phobia did Mark have the most freaking
funny scream ever oh wow oh man this is
going back far I think it was three
oh wow phobia kid that was a while ago
that was a great game too
really scary I think it was three I
think it was doing episode three yes
just referring to it's that one
oh man
it was so long ago I guess it wasn't all
that long because that was my old
apartment in Cincinnati oh man oh man if
you guys haven't seen phobia please
watch it's one of my favorites that I've
done continue to the last question I
can't believe her remember that holy
crap he's markable are good at archery
wait probably archery probably probably
probably as in probably archery well
done completes continue the last floor I
thought that was odd oh yeah six
question seven floors that's right hello
what time rhett and Link hi hey there
marker Ino it's interesting that we
should stumble upon each other like this
so you guys made that quiz naturally we
wanted to ask you something not another
stupid question I hope would you like to
join us on our podcast today mark it'll
be great fun we could even make a song
sounds fantastic I was on their podcast
it was a lot of fun we talked about a
lot of really cool things
so Mario bar had a bunch of fun
recording a podcast with rhett and Link
which is what I did
two hours later which is actually about
how long we were recording was that it
oh that was it oh I thought it was gonna
be a bit more to that oh that's why I
went up that whole thing for a marklar
quiz well whoop-dee-do look at me okay
so now what do I do
was there a point to any of that this
place seems nice it's why what do you
think the piano is not playing itself I
will be learning the piano pretty soon I
am learning to sing and I'm learning the
guitar at the moment and I can't wait to
learn other cool stuff I really do want
to make music and it's slowly good hello
Oh ladies unaware things are getting
interesting unless someone was abducted
nothing that's just terrible okay so
what why why was there ladies at hello
hi let's take a rapid left turn oh hi
Bob what is it madman
up in this [ __ ] Bob what did tiny buxom
do to you
whoa man I'm dark Bob when a dark
appliers henchman you can call me Bob
okay hi Dobb are you Bob
are you dead you will never understand
our great taste in music
Wade as if I made the dark way God some
stupid gut so stupid oh okay all right
well that's just a lightful right why is
there a toilet in here that's a good
question hello I hope this is a prob
okay little grim to have a grave in here
hey is okay bye
shall I leave the building no is there
some reason I need to be here sorta
weird to have holes in the floor so
weird to have blood on the floor okay
all right
just don't tell anyone about this place
I'm better than you
keep dreaming buddy okay I don't know
what the hell just happened or what I
just experienced what oh man this is it
the left side is so much more involved
than the right side what I'm tell me
roscas
I don't dance dance with me okay
cool okay I jumped on the couch cool
what's the point of all this okay I'm
not gonna dig through Toby's task but
I'm gonna look at all but by Toby yeah
by Japanese that wasn't even dark Toby
that wasn't even dark rhettandlink
what's going on this is a police station
okay good
hey there can anyone help me I are born
on earth do you need you buffoon hold on
Ryan this could be a case let's indigo
what we were very busy wait I got to
remember later please actually was you
boys better not have your pants on you
boys your boys better not have your
pants on been drinking some alcohol
doing what exactly we have a very
important business it's downs birthday I
need help
a tiny boxes a tiny box who's getting
interesting
you guys are sick anyway tiny boxes
wrecked my home I probably kidnapped my
friends
also there's da band-aid and
everything's just weird
requesting permission to throw this
loony in the slammer boss branded Oh sir
do not move you're under arrest
what why for disturbing the police on a
very special man's birthday I'm outta
here
if you haven't seen Alan that's the
wharfs - a fair part - or something like
that I gotta find a place to hide oh my
god oh my god oh oh my god oh no oh okay
resisting is futile and I'm dead and I
haven't saved in a while
great I love that okay here we go come
on we're gonna find a place to hide it's
not gonna be stupid it's not gonna be
stupid I'm going in Toby's a god damn it
okay I don't know where you want me to
go I don't know
oh come on you son of a [ __ ]
you son of a [ __ ] your side of the [ __ ]
yo oh here we go I ducked down in the
sewer okay I didn't think of that before
because I goddamn it you sons of [ __ ]
if you get me I'm gonna be strong cursed
hi
okay I got cornered oh we're in an
elevator huh okay here we go now running
and okay here we go okay bye oh oh oh
that little [ __ ] sure is fast Oh we'll
get some rest then take them down okay
okay what the [ __ ] happened with the
path looks like someone redesigned it
with a more naturalistic touch great
sweet nothing beats the taste of radical
soda I'm sure that's true
hello a bag obtained uh I'm in the bag
why do I have a ham in the bag
why doesn't everybody have a ham in the
bag I'm asking so many questions
how all bar high get down here right now
Tim I need a word with you hardwood why
name is hard Lord shut up your sack of
[ __ ] I've had enough of you ruining my
house my garden my path my life and most
of all I'm sick of you killing my
friends boy I've been trying to be as a
designer a follower I did it was great
Jay your trap do you think you can do
anything but you ever wanted destroying
property killing people taking but blood
mark I've never killed anyone in my life
Oh Hongki you tried to kill wide my
buddy didn't die did he oh well you
killed Jack I found him dead inside your
mansion well Jack died inside my mansion
hurry book you lawyer what is you see I
never even do that Jack wasn't my
console double Goodwin you say you found
him dead what's her injury did he have
well uh he had wait a minute
you killed yamimash oh right get down
here and
by a bastard mano-a-mano manda man I
don't like dogs I go to camp here ha I
got a ham in a bag you gon take a ham in
the back in the face oh what's out a ham
the bag was my patented ham in the bag
better than a soap in a sock shut your
mouth I'm gonna go say my friends
jackass why sure I mean oh I'm sure you
will but I got the ham in the bag now
uh-huh okay
oh no that's a little sweeter from
presentable liberty oh no that's so cute
okay so am I supposed to do something
about that mystical mystical circle I
have no idea
oh hi oh wait I'm back home
okay so G's is really hot here seven
point eight out of ten too much lava
okay so wonder this thing hasn't
evaporated oh why is there a living
hellscape inside my home now uh oh god
no you do sit up ahh
yep
okay that would have been much easier if
I hadn't been such a prick guys don't
worry I'll get you out of there
oh no I'll kind of haha
Yolo save your friends oh hardwood how
nice of you to join us when the big boss
gets here he's gonna ah
why are you doing don't worry hardwood
you'll be fine
wow I've had enough
you guys okay in there we're a little
roughed up mark but we're okay
quickly get us out don't listen to date
or Dobb
you didn't ask you wait Bob everyone
okay
yes mark but seriously get us out of
here quickly before Bob Bob comes back
come on guys the dangers gone we got
nothing to worry about
hey how did hardwood even get you in
there he's not exactly more powerful
than all of you it's because he wasn't
the one who put us in here
get us out now whoa wait where's my
sweet Danny Oh No
oh hi Wow why I am right here mark hi ah
[ __ ] mah shoulders bleeding for some
reason I don't suppose that hurt Bob use
the wharf said you can't monster took it
I'm Erin monster are you sure you should
be calling your best buddy that Erin oh
he's got me pinned up against the wall
no I should thank you for returning my
memory without you flicking that switch
I would have lived out my life as a
regular being okay what do you mean I'm
a little bloodied up you see I am not a
regular person here's my chance
ow that wasn't my chance ooh that's
fighting dirty let him go just keep
standing as I was saying I am NOT a
regular person I am a god you're crazy
Danny snap out of it
ow again without mark you know I could
have just thrown you into the lava but
I'm having too much fun
Oh unmanly zel how old I guess I can
hear someone coming
you there hold it
we saw everything
prepare to die freak Oh Oh No - Oh too
bad looks like you missed me want to
give it another dogs No yummy damn it
not again
No you sort of a [ __ ] oh oh oh stop it
Ryan he's too fast you you disgusting
son of a [ __ ] yeah ow again still alive
are you I can't do it I'm sorry everyone
oh and now you will die oh my god okay
oh yeah Yami's a dragon I forgot it's a
dragon he's a goddamn dragon oh yeah
yeah I can have two more I bet I can use
it awesome
walking out dear mark I'll bet I could
use a spirit form here for some reason
hi
what did you Spyro the Jack yeah Tom the
kicks of us now I can
Jack now I can't do a jacksepticeye
impression I went to the spirit world -
right
that means I could get one - oh I can't
wait for this what oh haha
quick we can circle them around and
humid well oh yeah yamimash
that works too I suppose yummy you saved
us all Wow oh but Danny's this pathetic
excuse for a god shall rot in hell for
all I care
ow ACK cough my oh not so tough with a
Pierce gut are you
Howie again half-half you forgotten
about one thing the wharf stashes secret
weakness is brutal bullets okay I
remember cuz I died or Worf stash died
that's right no but I am a god funk all
right then mark are you okay
yeah totally fine Wade just multiple
stab wounds to the bud hey I'm just
trying to help help me by picking me up
um okay a cow herds Marc that Danny that
has been had went almost right three we
need to get you to dr. Branton Oh
how will you explain your state to your
fans oh don't pressure me Bob I'll just
tell them I had a blockage in my
intestines or something yeah this is
what really happened see Danny he went
crazy turned into a God who weirdest
thing then we all like got together in
the middle of hell did I mention we were
in hell also tiny about Sam has two
forms and one of them is evil I killed
him so then he stabbed me in the gut
when after yamimash turned into a dragon
whose greatest thing
oh we watched too much gain of Thrones
and yeah or all right
the blockage here I'll help you why did
this happen I'm Aaron I don't know what
to tell you Aaron it seems like a lot of
things happen for no reason around here
maybe we'll find the right answer
someday ready to get rid of the body
down you got it don't want this thing to
come alive again hmm
yeah don't forget about me I was here
the whole time I forgot John's ear and
so markiplier took a trip to the
hospital in critical condition
whilst his loving friends fickt ups who
fixed up his house the best they could
before long the manly markiplier was
fighting fit again indeed I was yay Wow
everyone the place looks great thanks
for fixing up my mansion that I
apparently live in I'm honored that you
I can call you guys my friends
aw shucks mark will always be here for
you mark mark my Joey while I was
picking up the broken hardwood pieces I
found this inside him taint a cell phone
ghoul it only has one contact in it and
it's called no turning back let's call
it hello who's that we dad hello hello
okay
ah that's right okay I get it yeah I did
I
the live story I got both of them done
oh man that was a lot of fun except for
the parts where it was a little bit
douchey but hey that happens whatever it
is what it is so that's the end of dance
with caution
thank you everybody someone for watching
excellent job you have successfully
completed a left or a side of course if
you haven't clear the right which I did
it's completely different game which is
amazing thanks for making a whole
different game blah blah blah wait oh no
tonight Oh No what did I miss the secret
was there a secret ending ah just Hooven
brood is that the name of the next game
I guess okay so that was dance with
caution thank you everybody so much for
watching this Thank You developer for
making these games I love love these fan
made games because they bring so much
out of the community that you know
everybody remembers these special
moments from the videos that I've done
in the past and recent past and like the
special events like me going in the
hospital not that that's a special event
to be celebrated but like it's just so
cool to see all the things that come out
of this community so you guys can help
too there's so many pieces of fan art
that are amazing and so many stories
that are told and so many things that
are made in this community go out and
tell someone that they did a great job
at it and they're doing a great job and
whatever they're doing like help someone
pursue their dreams and help someone
just feel a little better today go out
there and tell someone that they're
amazing because someone needs to hear it
so thank you everybody so much for
watching
you are absolutely amazing and remember
to keep dancing the night away thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
oh my god